so what do you sell makes a good voice
performance then
and is it something that has to be in
english or does it have
can you recognize it in like japanese
yeah japanese too but i think that's
just from watching a lot of japanese
media
yeah it's something that you can because
the way you deliver a line
anything right the way i visu a line
there's a
uh when you deliver a singular line
there's a visualization to it of
if you imagine the pacing and the pitch
like that in my head
with a good line there's a set where it
should be delivered right and that's the
way the director wants it to and
i imagine like someone like quentin
tarantino has the same idea it's like
the line is delivered
the way i see it yeah yeah and so it's
like
i just visualize in my head the way it
should go like if you should raise your
voice how you should raise your pitch
and then
when you should take it down when you
should slow it down when you should out
of pause
and it's really interesting seeing how
like some of the actors will deliver a
certain line and where they'll choose to
take pauses
or how they'll choose to slow words down
i think that's really interesting
oh i'm the same like you know i haven't
done as much voicing yeah
but yeah i definitely take a keen eye to
voice acting as well because i also want
to get better at it yeah and i
i i totally get what you mean with the
cult curve there's the way i wish that
like
i wish i had figured out a way where i
could definitively show people what i
mean in my head right yeah about that
because
if you put the line on like an axis of y
and that like
x you know it would go like that right
yeah it would be like right you need to
pause here you need to take
a break here slow down this word this
word's in italics so please put emphasis
on it but not too much emphasis yeah
bold yeah it's like really loads of
nuances that
we don't see as the audience that i'm
trying in my head when i'm listening to
something
i'm imagining how they saw the script
yeah i'm trying to think back to what
they were thinking
so like depending on what medium we're
in now like and also
ever since i got way too into voice
acting i see so much adr and it puts me
the [ __ ] off in films when you can hear
one line that's delivered in the room
yep and one line whether you did it in
post
yeah it's so grating when you hear
because like so many sitcoms do this
where they like have the line done in
post yeah you don't realize how many
movies are done in post as well
they've done so well then yeah yeah i've
definitely noticed it
recently when i was like yeah like when
you noticed it once you can't
stop noticing it i noticed and and
that's the problem i have with
um watching shows that are dubbed in
languages like
uh you know italian or whatever or dutch
normally
they're they have to dub so many shows
where they're just pumping this out and
there's not really much given to the
sound of it and it sounds like
everyone's in a studio
every single tv show they're in no
matter where they go when i hear this
italian or this dutch guy speak
it always sounds like they're in a
studio when they're outside it's like
what the [ __ ] i hate that so much
and that's the reason why when people
are like oh i watch i had a german
friend who watched game of thrones in
dutch or a german sorry dubbed
and i was like why it sounds like
everyone's in a studio they want a
battlefield no
it's like it's exactly the same as thai
dubs when i was talking about
dubs and they just don't know audio
mixing so instead of like making it
sound like they're in the environment
they're in
it's always in the same studio and
instead of like mixing in the voices
they just like quiet
every other voice and every other sound
every other sound so the voices are just
like 10 times louder than every sound
effect every time someone talks and then
the sound effects get louder again oh my
god
it's like the worst kind of audio mixing
that's lazy as [ __ ]
yeah i mean now i'm not sure if they did
it back then but now commonly the
japanese uh
studios will just give uh basically a
track with just the voices taken out
yeah and they're like
here's everything we've done it all for
you just add the voices yeah you're
normally quite easy
um but yeah in terms of dubbing or voice
performances in
anime cartoons that's a whole different
like i feel like i feel like
one unsung hero in terms of like voice
acting and dubbing
is the voice director because i i feel
like
obviously you know actors get a lot of
the credits but i feel
they also get all the [ __ ] and i feel
like the voice director has so much
control over
how good this voice performance is going
to be because i've definitely
worked with voice actors and actresses
in my own bridge series
where they've done a great [ __ ] job
and then i see them voicing like other
projects
and it's terrible it's it's bad yeah it
hurts me because i know
the potential that these voice actors
have um and i know
that it's probably just bad voice
direction you know
and a lot of people would don't think
about that or don't know that because
they just think oh that
it's a shitty voice actor you know yeah
it's a real shame
it's difficult because unless you've
been in an environment where you've
worked with a director
or had someone directing you in any way
it's really hard to understand the role
of a director
yes i didn't quite get it until i had
worked in that space
and it's kind of the person who like
because when you're doing it for
yourself and you're acting
you're in your own head you're your
worst enemy because you're like [ __ ] i
should have done it this way
because when i record for one of my own
videos 20 takes
i record for someone else with a
director one or two takes yeah because
they tell me what they want and they
help me get there and a lot of people
like there's ten percent of voice actors
who can deliver lines
amazingly without a director yeah but
then there's like 50 percent who need a
director
yeah and there's like 30 40 percent who
let's be honest
it's not to say that but it's one of
those things where you do need like a
good ear somewhat
it's a skill absolutely it's definitely
a skill because i i personally think i'm
a much
better voice director than i am a voice
yeah yeah
even though i've done both i try to like
insert my own voice as little as
possible whenever i'm
doing kind of any kind of voice work
that i've done before
but i've really enjoyed directing
because it's it's
it's definitely a unique skill because
i've seen how other people direct
their their work as well and it's
everyone has a different style
some are just not effective at at all
some some
some voice directors you know they they
have no idea what they want no
you know and yeah i mean it's just on
the voice actor to save
to save the performance somehow even
though the director has no idea what
they want
um do you ever get that moment though
when you're directing someone
and you they've not delivered the line
exactly the way you want it and so you
have to explain it to them
and you get to the third point yeah the
third it's the third time
the third time you've tried and they
still haven't
done it the way you want it to do do you
continue
like do you continue trying to explain
it to them or do you just go with one of
the takes
normally i will do i would try my best
to explain it to them
yeah um worst case scenario i'll do
a line read which line read is uh you
don't normally do it it's kind of it's
not unprofessional but it
wastes a lot of time which is where the
director will deliver the line and i'll
be like just copy what i just did
yeah and that's what i'll do on the
worst case scenario and if they can't do
that
then it's like [ __ ]
this is going to be bad like if they if
they can't hear want like
what i just did yeah and they can't
replicate it that means that they have
no idea what i just did
yeah in my head i'm like okay they don't
even see what i did they don't know what
they're doing
yeah yeah it's the worst feeling in the
world isn't it
it's pretty awful